[Music]
let's go to ann and peter pan and saint
louis what's up anne
oh
not too much how we
doing i am okay
oh that usually means not great not
great
well
uh yes
so um
so good well i'm gonna come up with a
smart uh yeah not good all right so tell
me what's up
okay um
i'll give you a little bit of backstory
i'll try to make it as short as possible
um
my husband and i have been married um
almost five years
and um
when we married um i in i say i
inherited three kids um
when his previous wife left um she
walked away
not totally but mostly
and so
together we've been raising
what excuse me what what does that mean
totally but not mostly or mostly but not
totally um
okay so
with
no warning like he thought they were
going to counseling they were trying to
work on things
um she
left okay like and couch hopped for two
years
so she would see the kids sometimes like
i mean she wasn't out of the town she'd
see them for like half an hour sometimes
she just showed up
just in and out like a like a yeah
okay all right and but there was no
formal arrangement or formula agreement
or anything like that she just would
show up there is but it's never been
like we technically have joint custody
but it's a joke okay okay all right um
okay so
um
so the kids were 12 10 and eight when we
got married and their life shifted
completely right um like
in a healthier better way but still a
major change like
we used to have tvs in our room and
jennifer's iran's very
anti-tvs in the room so that disappeared
and we moved and started a new school
and
um
you know
we go to church and they love to go to
church every sunday but they didn't do
that before and we used to have
unlimited screen time and we don't do
that anymore and like
just
big big life changes um
and i want to throw one out there that i
want to make sure we don't blow by okay
um their mom left them
oh i know so
regardless of the sea change if we don't
do it we don't do entertainment like
this or it's not free reign here there's
new rules in town there's new sheriff in
town that's all
stuff that's fine like their environment
their mama left them
right so when you say like their life's
for the better i would say it's super
not now maybe the structure in their
life and all that's better but their mom
looked at him and said i'd rather go do
something else than y'all you see what
i'm saying so
major trauma major like i think one of
the core traumas a person can experience
right mom leaving them so i
100 agree and i'm gonna tell you more
trauma that she keeps piling up okay
okay all right
um
okay so
we have had problems with our oldest
from
kind of the beginning like first it
started with i can't sleep well yep you
know this is a kid that like
got straight a's very
you know
rule follower kind of kid can't sleep
um she's also
probably on the spectrum but she also
got diagnosed this year with conversion
disorder and what what have you all done
as parents
to
rally around this young woman
we have
we've
spent time together we've i mean we've
talked are like tried to listen try to
be like what feelings are going on what
situations we've gone to
at least two counselors maybe more
um
we
anyway like
more and more and more uh y'all put in
the effort that's what i'm just getting
at that y'all you are trying okay
on may 1st
our oldest attempted suicide so our kid
just got out of a mental hospital not
very long ago her mother who they see
periodically
um
now has
a nasty but home where they can go
um has had a relationship now two years
ago she told our oldest that she was in
a polyamorous relationship okay which
you know exacerbated things also
but now
it was like
why did why did that exacerbate things
okay so
boy long distance polyamorous boyfriend
is now moving in okay
so there are going to be two
boyfriends living in the house
and i might i didn't mention this but my
younger daughter
um she has been to the counseling also
has attachment disorder tends to be
very
super friendly with men like
inappropriately friendly because she's
so desperate for attention
we're terrified our kids are going
to be
molested
we are not okay with our kids going to
stay at this house anymore okay
um we don't know how to talk about this
in a way that
i mean
that says
let me we don't want you to hate your
mom we want you to love your mom as best
you can but
so here's we're not okay with putting
you in a dangerous situation yes so
here's a
i'm gonna make some broad assumptions
okay and feel free to interrupt me and
tell me if i'm wrong
okay
um how long have you and your husband
been married
it will be five years at the end of this
month okay all right
yeah i wrote that down five years so
in the last five years and particularly
the last three years
the world has unspooled on all of us
particularly on y'all
yeah and you have had a ringside seat
to a beautiful young 12 year old who is
now a struggling beautiful
17 year old
yes oh did i mention i also had a baby
in this time might as well why not let's
just make this work
yeah and as a parent you're watching
this happen as you're watching a
slow-motion
car crash
and you're doing what you can
what you what you know to do
and at the same time you've got another
little one who was 10 at the time who's
now
15. who i i don't like saying kids are
desperate for attention
i like saying they are desperate for
love
right okay i mean i mean whatever you
want to say well and here here's what
yeah if someone's like just desperate
for attention like i'm like shut up go
away
if i see some kid who is desperate for
connection
that's a totally different thing
right that's somebody asking me for air
or asking me for a sip of water that's a
different thing than then i just want to
be the center of attention right right
okay so
as a parent
as somebody who feels like they're
losing control of everything
it is real easy
to try to gain control in as many ways
as you can in all the other areas where
you think you can drill down
i will tell you
that
um it is a hundred percent in you and
your husband's right
to
want to know
who else is in the home of the ex from
or in any home where my kids happen to
be
period
right if it's if it's a friend's house
if it's um
a cousin's house or if it's their
birth mom's home
and she happens to have two strange men
in the house
let's take the polyamory let's take the
fact that they're all dating let's take
that out that confuses it right because
that rolls us into our morals our our
our judgments and it makes everything
more chaotic than needs to be okay let's
move that over for a second
let's just say there are two strange
dudes in that house and i got two
teenage daughters i'm not sending them
into that
the idea that because they are all
dating
means they're more likely to sexually
assault and molest a child isn't
accurate i've never read that data
anywhere
and i want to be careful not to lob
grenades like that because here's why it
muddies the case for
um
it starts adding variables and judgments
to places that don't need them
now i don't think it's wise
i think it's ill-advised and i would
tell anybody this with love in my heart
to have two live-in boyfriends that
you're sleeping with at the same time
that's a recipe for disaster okay it
just is
um
and it's okay as parents to say i don't
want i don't want my kids getting of
that
model as an alternative presentation of
what love looks like that's okay
but to suggest then and they're probably
molesters that's that's where the whole
argument your kids are going to roll
their eyes here's a good example if you
tell your kids
if you drink a beer you know what
happens cancer and death
in drunk driving and then the one time
they sneak a beer and they wake up the
next morning and they're they're still
alive what they do right then that
moment is they say i wonder what else
they lied to me about
and so i have to tell my kids who are 12
and 6. sex is incredible it's awesome
and it's not for 12 and six year olds
and then i insert i tell them my values
right
so
here's the
back out of the polyamory thing
a hundred percent y'all should be bold
and feel really good
about saying i am not going to put my
kids in a situation where there's
revolving men in a home or two strange
men if those two men want to come meet
me and my husband for lunch and we're
going to talk through what this looks
like cool but otherwise i'm not doing
that
and i'll go to court over it and i'll
fight you over fill parches in the
parachute we'll fill in the blank okay
right we'll have that conversation and
then in a separate conversation
with my 17 year old and of course my 15
year old
i would absolutely have the conversation
here's how we think love should work
and here's what a healthy relationship
looks like
um we don't agree with your mom's
decision to have two live-in boyfriends
and try to make a uh what they call it a
throuple i think this is the word like
to try to make that work um
that's not something that we think is
wise
and
we're not going to talk bad about your
mom so we want we want you all to know
we are intentionally modeling what we
think a healthy a healthy romantic
relationship looks like and that's where
you can leave it being distraught and
raged out will not change the situation
yeah what here's what that will happen
though your kids will absorb that
tension and they will think it's their
fault
because they will connect the dots that
every time they go to mom's house
um stepmom and dad get crazy
it must be us
and every time i come over here and go
back the other way it's a little bit
quieter
birth mom doesn't care so it must be
safe forever you see what i'm saying
and so i want to i mean we don't i i
know you don't i don't know
i know you don't yeah no we it's that
it's that we don't want them to
to have all of that yeah and so i think
it's identifying we choose to to live
healthy relationships this way because
and you and your husband may have never
had that conversation you may just be
like i'm not having uh my husband's not
bringing in a living girlfriend with us
you all may have not sat down and said
hey here's what we think a healthy
relationship looks like are we modeling
that
that's a
killer conversation to have with a 17
year old and a 15 year old and a 12 year
old that's a great conversation to have
yeah and then tell them hold us
accountable if you don't see us doing
that
great and now we're going to start
entering into that conversation and when
their mother situation falls apart which
100 chance it will and the internets are
going to get mad at me for saying that
it will the chances of them all being 92
two 92 year old dudes and her living out
their best like riding off into the
sunset together are zero they're just
zero right um yeah no and i think he's
like he just graduated from college so
like
we're 40 and i think he's 25. excellent
excellent excellent so
when this falls apart which it will yeah
what your kids do not need is then i
told you so they don't need it
right they need a picture of stability
that's been that's existed the entire
time
and that's what you can offer them
not the i no man
and be real clear with mom
i'm not just gonna have strange dudes
coming over the house not with my 15
year old daughter and my 17 year old
daughter it's not gonna happen
and expect your daughters to put one and
one and one together and come up with
seven and say oh it's because you all
hate mom and you hate us
and we hate you we've already been down
that road that's right mom already
talked to the oldest about it that's
exactly right stay on your ground hold
your values yeah
and be a person of dignity and respect
if you feel your body getting fired up
and worked up say out loud i need to
take a minute
like this
the idea of putting you in an unsafe
situation hurts my heart and i need to
take a second and i'll circle back to
you and now i'm modeling what
frustration and healthy response that
frustration looks like to my teenage
daughters which is a gift that every
teenager needs see what i'm saying this
can be
this this mess of a situation which it
is
can be an extraordinary opportunity 10
years down the road
because now y'all are playing a long
game with these little ones right
uh what does mom say about the does she
say y'all are mean or crazy or abusive
what does she say or you're just not
progressive enough or what what what
does she say
um well
we kind of try to
i guess
the one conversation that i have heard
um
is that
she claims that
she is no longer involved with one of
the men and that he's just a roommate
now
and the other one is now her boyfriend
and she's been dating him for four years
this is a traditional relationship i
mean it was slightly untraditional when
she was dating both of them at the same
time but now it's just one and do you
see do you see how do you see how
getting into the middle of who's dating
who not it doesn't matter who cares no
yeah yeah i'm just out of that i don't i
don't want to know anything that's right
i don't want to keep up with it i don't
want to know about here's what i know
i'm not going to put my daughters in a
situation where there's a cadre of men
that i don't know that i don't trust and
that i don't know have her best interest
at heart
full full stop and that's at school
that's at friend's house that's it
ex-wife's house and i'll take you to
court over it i'll spend money over it
but we're not doing this right that is
totally different and we're going to
talk about values in our home like i
would expect anybody to talk about their
values right right and so all the time
like
i think it's super important to to put
out there and not just assume they're
gonna absorb it okay i want you to hang
on to what i'm about to say and and um
hang on to this
i want you to provide
a living breathing
reality
that shows why
the way you and your husband choose to
do adult relationships
is a better alternative
and you won't provide that by yelling
and screaming nothing that you do but
you won't provide that by becoming a
taser you're gonna provide that by
having a home that feels safe and a home
that feels warm and patience and being
kind
and standing up when you just stand up
by standing up in a way that's under
control and honorable
not one of i can't take it anymore
that's something that children can
anchor into
and i hear and
this isn't you and i'm just
extrapolating this broadly to people
listening
i heard this recently i maybe even
talked about the show um somebody said
what if instead of yelling all the time
trying to burn down everything that we
don't agree with
we just created such incredible
alternatives we built such incredible
things that it rendered the other stuff
obsolete
and if i double down on how good my
marriage can be
and i create a space between me and my
wife that allows my kid to anchor into
that my two kids to anchor into that and
that they can't wait to get home just
because it feels safe it's not a charged
environment
and where we listen to them and we hold
them accountable we do all that stuff
together
[Music]
they're going to lean into that safety
they're going to lean into that
because it's peaceful
right that's the fruit there
and so
instead of worrying about ah that's good
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna show you
here's what this looks like and that's
how people's hearts are gonna change and
that's gonna allow your kids to
and don't forget those girls are going
to be doing whatever they can for a long
long time
to figure out what they did wrong
that made mom leave
and the best you can do is walk
alongside them and say you're enough
you're enough you're enough and they're
going to do any number of things to try
to prove to mom that they're worth being
loved
and they're going to need you in their
ear
you're enough you're enough
i love you you're enough